so I recently found a tick tock account
called homath where he basically breaks
down
what women are saying and I thought it
was hilarious that finally
the women are we're actually telling on
ourselves on Tick Tock and he just
really you know
breaks it down so go ahead
only 15 percent of women show an
interest in five eight men on dating
apps I don't know what I would do if I
was short this is a hard time for short
men I this is why dating apps are
terrible when a woman is looking at a
dating app she can just look at numbers
on the screen and set who she does and
does not want to talk to real life is
different I once went out with a girl
and when I showed up she said hey I
thought you were six foot three and I
said no I don't lie on my profile and I
made her check and then she saw that I
was right and she said oh okay and then
we went and had a beer but she was
disappointed that I was five foot eleven
I guess she was talking to a lot of guys
we had fun anyway I also have a friend
who is five foot nine and he once told
me a story about meeting a girl and
flirting with her and she said well
you're short and I don't usually date
short guys and he didn't know what to do
with that and nothing ever happened and
my advice for him is the same as my
advice for you if you're in the don't
matter Zone with me technically I'm in
it too and that is that when when that
girl said usually I don't usually date
short guys what she meant was keep going
give me a reason
there are visible things about you and
there are invisible things about you
maybe you're funny or you're smart or
you're romantic and it takes women
longer to see those but they do see them
my five foot nine friend he uh got
married to an attractive intelligent
woman and they have a child which it
will grow up to be probably five foot
nine have the same problems but the
point is you can do it you just have to
go outside get get off the apps go
outside and tell women what's good about
you
don't get black pilled you can do it
it's possible
so okay the funny thing is and I I
actually 100 agree with him especially
because I just think as a society we
always talk about all men are awkward
but I think women were just as awkward
we just get away with it because you
know we're like pretty and stuff so the
guys guys don't even care if you're
awkward but okay so
women filter out
men below six foot that is the most
common pick on the dating apps is they
just so if I was a dude I would lie I
would lie on dating apps I would
absolutely lie because the thing is he
is right women will date shorter but it
the shorter guys kind of have to have
something to make up for it but the
issue with tradcons is I just think a
lot of trade cons are a bit oblivious to
just how picky the women are think about
it we've had eighty percent of men as
ugly eighty percent so I don't know if I
was a guy that was five three five four
I don't know what the hell I would do
today's market he had another video so
let's pull it up things I did not know
about men in my 20s except I'm still 20
but oh so then you did know them see
this is Peak female reasoning it doesn't
all make sense but she feels it she says
four things number one no men want
girlfriends that is false a lot of these
guys do it's just that you see them as
no one
number two most men are broke well yeah
most people are broke human beings
organize themselves into hierarchies
what do you want everyone wins it can't
I'm broke you want some oatmeal
number three if we wanted to then we
would and that is true unless we can't
so if he can and he won't he's not gonna
and number four he knows if he wants to
date you in the first 10 minutes that is
that's pretty true low rate of change on
that one but more importantly uh women
are confused that men know what they
want
buddy we're confused that men women
women project constantly so we
constantly project the way we feel onto
men so we're confused that they know
what they want because we don't know
what we want like it changes every
single day and even illogical things if
we feel a certain way
it does it doesn't even matter like if
we feel a certain way then we believe
it's true
um and the other thing is I think women
we have no idea just how much we really
only look at the top guys again women
again women find 80 percent of men is
ugly not unattractive not okay but ugly
and women usually I mean I think with
the a million videos we come out with
all these fat chicks saying that they're
tense can come to the conclusion that
most women overrate their beauty and
think they're more beautiful than they
are